all right so we begin this newshour with
a growing military standoff sparked by
the crisis on ukraine's border with
russia a u.s president joe biden is
ordering the pentagon to deploy
additional troops to eastern europe two
thousand american soldiers will head to
poland and germany and 1000 will be
repositioned to romania the u.s and nato
already have tens of thousands of troops
of course in europe but russia's
president vladimir putin he says the
west is trying to lure him into a war
with ukraine and insist that moscow's
concerns about nato's expansion eastward
have been ignored russia has amassed
tens of thousands of soldiers on its
border with ukraine uk prime minister
boris johnson has said any invasion
would be a disastrous miscalculation
he's due to hold a phone call with putin
uh later on wednesday you remain focused
on the evolving situation in europe and
russia's actions
belarus
as the secretary said the united states
stands shoulder shoulder with our nato
allies
the current situation demands that we
reinforce the deterrent and defensive
posture on nato's eastern flank
president biden has been clear
that the united states will respond to
the growing threat to europe's security
and stability
our commitment to nato article 5 and
collective defense remains ironclad
as part of this commitment and to be
prepared for a range of contingencies
the united states will soon move
additional forces to romania
poland and germany
i want to be very clear about something
these are not permanent moves
they are moves designed to respond to
the current security environment
moreover
these forces are not going to fight in
ukraine
they are going to ensure the robust
defense
of our nato allies
now let me lay this out for you
in a series of three steps
first
one thousand soldiers
that are currently based in germany will
reposition to romania in the coming days
now this is a striker squadron a mounted
cavalry unit that's designed to deploy
in short order
and to move quickly once in place
and they will augment the some
900 u.s forces that are currently in
romania
this force is designed to deter
aggression and enhance our defensive
capabilities in front-line allied states
and we expect them as i said to move in
coming days
secretary austin discussed this
repositioning to romania just last week
in his conversation with the romanian
minister of defense
and again i want to stress
that this move is coming at the express
invitation
of the romanian government
additionally we welcome french president
macron's announcement that france
intends to deploy forces to romania
under nato command
which secretary austin discussed with
the french defense minister florence
parley just last week
the united states will continue to
consult and coordinate with france and
all our allies
to ensure that we complement each other
in our respective deployments
and of course we're going to continue to
work through nato to make appropriate
defensive and non-escalatory force
posture alignments
second
we are moving
uh an additional force of about
approximately 2 000 troops from the
united states to europe in the next few
days
the 82nd airborne division is deploying
components of an infantry brigade combat
team and key enablers to poland and the
18th airborne corps
is moving a joint task force capable
headquarters to germany both of them as
you know are based in fort bragg north
carolina
collectively
this force is trained and equipped for a
variety of missions to deter aggression
and to reassure
and to defend our
allies not surprisingly we worked very
closely with our polish and german
allies to set the stage for these
movements and we absolutely appreciate
their support
again these are not permanent moves
they respond to current conditions we
will adjust our posture as those
conditions evolve
third and finally
all of these forces are separate and in
addition to
the 8 500 personnel in the united states
on heightened alert posture that i
announced last week those 8 500 are not
currently being deployed but remain
ready to move if called
for the nato response force or as needed
for other contingencies as directed by
the secretary or by president biden
we continue to review our forced posture
and the situation in europe and we will
make adjustments as the situation
warrants
i also want to take this opportunity to
correct some misconceptions around last
week's announcement nato as an
organization does not have veto power
over u.s troop deployments and media
reports to the contrary represent a
mischaracterization of that
nothing precludes the united states from
making its own decisions on forced and
forced movements
including those forces that are being
placed
on heightened readiness
that said
any movement of u.s forces involves
consultation with the host nation as we
have done with romania and poland and
germany
prior to today's announcements
and we're mindful of the competing needs
of operational security and our
obligation to be transparent and we'll
provide you additional information on
these and other movements as available
and as appropriate
as we have long said we are continuously
reviewing our posture so there may soon
be additional posture decisions to
announce including movements that are
part of ongoing military exercises this
is not the sum total of the deterrence
actions we will take
or those to reassure our allies
i think it won't surprise you we take a
theater-wide approach to deterrence and
defense and we welcome the additional
announcements
uh by spain denmark the uk and the
netherlands of their consideration to
deploy additional forces to reinforce
nato's eastern flank the united states
has robust capabilities distributed
across europe including in the baltic
region and we will continue to assess
needs in that area in cooperation with
the relevant allies and of course
the full nato alliance
we stand united we have said that
repeatedly we say it again today
these movements are unmistakable signals
to the world that we stand ready to
reassure our nato allies and to turn and
defend
against any aggression
now as the secretary said friday
we do not know if russia has made a
final decision
to further invade ukraine
but it clearly has that capability
the department of defense will continue
to support diplomatic efforts led by the
white house and the state department to
press for resolution
we do not believe conflict is inevitable
the united states in lockstep with our
allies and partners has offered russia a
path to de-escalate
but we will take all prudent measures to
assure our own security and that of our
allies
now finally just one note i
i note that in the past few hours a
proposal made by the united states
leaked to a european news outlet
we did not make this document public
but now that it is
it confirms
to the entire world what we have always
been saying there is no daylight between
our public statements and our private
discussions
nato and its partners are unified in
their resolve and open to constructive
and serious diplomacy the united states
has gone the extra mile to find a
diplomatic solution and if russia
actually wants to negotiate a solution
as it claims it does
this document certainly makes clear that
there is a path forward to do so
and with that we'll take questions
starting with you lita
hi john thanks um just a couple details
on some of this
is it still 8 500 total
that are on prepare to deploy orders or
are there additional ones
and um there's a brigade at uh fort
carson that is all that already is
scheduled to rotate into europe are you
including them there's been some
confusion are you including that person
brigade
in the prepare to deploy orders
or the is are they completely separate
because they're an already scheduled
deployment
and then um
one other are are there
um
more are these troops that are going are
they under nato
or are these all unilateral u.s moves
thank you
let me see if i can remember all those
uh the troops that i'm talking about
today will be going under u.s command
um but as i said uh in the case of
romania we know the french are going to
be uh preparing to deploy troops there
we will find ways to complement that
forced presence again in full
consultation with romania
so i wouldn't describe these as
unilateral moves i mean this is a
bilateral uh arrangement between the
united states and romania but to your
question they will be going under u.s
command
um the 8 500
they still remain on prepare to deploy
uh orders uh as i said when i talked
about it last monday the vast majority
of them are designed for the nato
response force as i said my opening
statement that at force has not been
activated so they aren't going anywhere
the the secretary has as you might
imagine as we have
worked towards
these troop movements
there have been additional forces put on
prepare to deploy orders or shortened
tethers i'm not prepared to go into
great detail today about that but yes
there have been additional ones and as i
said in my opening statement you can
expect that that that could continue to
happen going forward we're going to
constantly look at the conditions
in the region and consult with allies
and partners and if we feel we need to
make additional forces more ready we'll
do that if we feel that we need to send
more forces to certain eastern flank
countries will do that too in full
consultation with nato and in full
consultation with the specific allies
and and partners and i think i missed
one of your questions leeda
um well i just want to i'm gonna have to
yeah i'm gonna have to take that one
lita because i i don't have the
uh
the breakdown of of uh of every single
uh unit in that in that original 8500 in
front of me so let me just take that
rather than speculate and guess jen
john do you have any evidence that putin
plans to move beyond ukraine's borders
why are you bolstering these eastern
flank allies if you do not have evidence
of that because it's important that we
send a strong signal to mr putin and
frankly to the world that nato matters
to the united states it made it matters
to our allies and we have
ironclad article five commitments an
attack on one is an attack on all and so
uh
we know that uh
that
that he also bristles uh at nato
about nato
and uh he has made no secret of that um
we are making it clear uh that we're
gonna be prepared to defend our nato
allies if it comes to that hopefully it
won't come to that nobody wants to see
as i said conflict's not inevitable
there's no reason for uh their for there
to be armed conflict in ukraine or
anywhere else on the european continent
and mr putin can go a long way to to
serving that end
uh by taking seriously the proposals
that we have put forward diplomatically
and by de-escalating through moving some
of those troops away but is there any
evidence that he plans to that anything
you're seeing that suggests those troops
that are
outside ukraine might carry on to poland
romania
what what we what we see jen is
clear evidence every day that he
continues to destabilize the environment
by adding more forces in the western
part of his country and around along
belarus in addition to
additional naval activity in the
mediterranean and the north atlantic so
he clearly is providing himself many up
options lots more capabilities for
exactly what purpose we don't know right
now and because we don't know exactly
what his purpose is we want to make sure
we're ready on the nato front to defend
our allies barbara i want to follow up
on tim
jenn's question you said at the
beginning the current situation demands
we reinforce
so what specifically
demands the reinforcement that you are
laying out today and the reason i asked
this this is
bilateral as you said originally
uh you spoke at length several days ago
about the nato response force they have
not activated that you are moving ahead
bilaterally
not under a nato umbrella
anyhow
so
what signal does that send that you're
not waiting for a nato vote
and what is the current situation that
demands this reinforcement
outside of russia outside of ukraine i
don't think i heard a specific answer i
think the
signal it sends that word that we're
moving
additional u.s forces
into allied territory at the request and
with the invitation of those countries
is that we take
our nato commitments very very seriously
uh and i put that right in the opening
statement um and as for i think your
question is
why now uh
here i don't understand
i don't i i'd like an explanation why
you're doing this now
without the vote at nato which does not
appear readily apparent for them to
activate the response force what has led
you to say okay
the united states will act on a
bilateral basis you have the invitations
you could have waited for a nato vote
you decided not to so what is that it's
not it's not just us barb other nations
and i mentioned denmark the uk france i
mean other nations other nato nations
are likewise um
discussing in bilateral ways with
eastern flank nations the addition of
forces and capabilities to those nations
so it's not just the united states it's
other nato allies that are doing this
and you you talk about this vote thing
let's be clear what i think you're
getting at is the nato response force
that's a 40 000 person strong force that
is designed for high readiness um and
that is a decision that the alliance and
the only of the alliance can make we
have a contribution to that
we have gotten those forces alerted to
be ready to go if needed and they still
will be we also can
if the president decides as
commander-in-chief to take some of those
alert and alerted forces and move them
in a bilateral arrangement as well he he
can do that
as i said at the top it's not like the
alliance has a veto authority on any of
those troops that were put on prepare to
deploy
but
in terms of why now here's just a couple
of factors
mr putin continues to add forces uh
combined arms offensive capabilities
even over just the last 24 hours he
continues to add in western russia and
in belarus and again as i said in the
mediterranean and the north atlantic he
has shown no signs of being interested
or willing to de-escalate the tensions
and it's not just the united states
that's noticed this our nato allies have
noticed this and we have been in
constant communication and consultation
with them and they have expressed their
concerns we have shared our perspectives
on what we're seeing with them
they have shared their perspectives on
what they're seeing with us and as a
result of these bilateral discussions we
are now prepared to make these moves i
say again two things these are temporary
moves not permanent deployments not you
know permanent basing and two we're not
ruling out the possibility that there
will be more coming up in future days
and weeks so my last question
the bottom line here is you cannot the
united states the pentagon the white
house you right now could not rule out
the possibility that putin could make a
move
outside of ukraine into an east european
country that's
uh
friendly with nato friendly with the us
and ally you can't rule out that he's
going to make an additional move beyond
ukraine we're not ruling anything in or
out with this announcement barb this
isn't about making this i don't this
isn't about an intel assessment about
what mr putin will or won't do
as i said again in my opening statement
we still don't believe he's made a
decision
uh to further invade ukraine
and if he does further invade ukraine
obviously there's going to be
consequences for that but he has many
options and capabilities available to
him as to how he might do that and we
simply don't know
we want to make sure
that he knows
any move on nato
is going is going to be resisted and
it's going to be it's going to trickle
trigger article 5 and we're going to be
committed to the defense of our allies
and that's what this is all about yeah
david
when
president biden
previewed this last week he said he'd be
sending forces in the near term he also
said
not a lot
um
is did you consider 3 000 not a lot and
how does
1 000 how do 1 000
troops infantry troops
stop
the kind of force that you've been
describing
that russia has been amassing in uh
western russia and belarus we think that
these orders that the secretary is
giving today uh are very much in keeping
with the president's comments
and
to your other question i i remind again
um
that we hold the option open
of
additional
force movements
if that's desired and needed
um
uh so the steps i'm talking about
uh
today
could very well be preliminary steps to
future ones that we might take um and to
your other question about you know is
that enough uh again i think it's worth
reminding that romania as a sovereign
state has their own military uh and a
very capable one at that
um and it's not just the united states
sending a striker squadron as i
mentioned earlier the the french are
gonna be sending additional troops i'll
let them speak to what they're gonna do
and on what timeline and uh and how much
and as i also said in my opening
statement other countries
are likewise
moving forward to provide bolstering
capabilities to nato allies on the
eastern flank
will it take these troops to get in
position do you expect the
infantry
combat team from fort bragg to jump in
i'm not going to talk about
the specifics of their movement
but as i said in my opening statement we
expect them to start moving in coming
days i don't have a more specific
timeline for you
in terms of exact departure date and
exact uh arrival
obviously it'll be it'll be obvious when
they get there and certainly will try to
keep you informed all the way in court i
i just want to see you've you've made it
clear several times that these troops
won't be brought into ukraine and they
won't be in combat but can you rule out
that any of these troops specifically
some from the 82nd airborne might be
brought into ukraine in the coming days
to help with a non-combatant evacuation
is that possible that they could be used
for that as i think you heard the
secretary uh say on friday
our troops are multi-mission capable and
they will be prepared for a range of
contingencies and i won't go any further
than that is that one reason though that
the 82nd specifically was identified as
one of the units to go forward early is
that because of that that capability
because they have impact they are as you
know already a ready force uh they are
already at a heightened state of alert
uh that's that's that's the the risen uh
true for that for that uh for that force
and uh they are
multi-mission capable they can do a lot
of things it's a very versatile
force and and i think their versatility
their ability to to move quickly
and to conduct a range of missions
across a range of contingencies uh which
is well proven that's the reason why the
secretary has ordered them to go
okay uh let me get i i promise i'll get
to everybody but i haven't done other
than lead i haven't done anybody on the
phone and i need to do that silly
no um thank you um
i would like to know how many um
soldiers you are going to send to poland
because you said 2 000
from us to germany and poland
so how many people how many soldiers
will will you have in poland all in all
the majority of the 2000 that will be
moving from fort bragg
will be going to poland
uh the
the
18th airborne corps as i said in my
opening statement
that's going to germany that they're
going to form a joint task force
headquarters uh and that's usually
depending on the the need and the task
at hand
several hundred people so the majority
of the 2000 that i mentioned uh that
comprise the 82nd airborne uh brigade
combat team they that that that leading
element there they'll be they'll be
going to poland
um kelly from news nation
hi john thanks for taking my question um
i know you said uh we will adjust this
posture as conditions evolve i was
curious because we're seeing you know
ordinary ukrainians teachers moms dads
dentists learning to use guns to defend
themselves there are calls in washington
for the pentagon to support them are any
of these troops going to help them and
how will the president's order change
the mission of the florida national
guard troops currently in ukraine as i
said at the at the top kelly that the
president's been clear and and i think
we've made it eminently clear in my
opening statement that these troops will
not be going to ukraine uh uh uh to
participate in the in the in the defense
of ukraine uh the president has been
very clear about that
these forces are going to to reassure
and to bolster capabilities inside
nato's eastern flank
and as for the florida national guard
trainers they are still in ukraine
there's been no decision to uh to change
their status
they are still there providing advice
and assist to ukrainian armed forces
and if and when there's a a need to make
a different decision about their
presence there the secretary will
absolutely do that in consultation with
the european command commander general
walters but no decision has been made
yet
uh tony capaccio
hey john when you said it will be
obvious that the 82nd airborne arrives i
want to piggyback on david martin's
question is it likely they're going to
parachute in as a symbolic drop to send
a message to putin yeah again i i don't
uh i'm not going to talk about the
their their travel there uh and uh and
how they're uh going to arrive uh i i
don't anticipate it will be a a
tactical operation in that regard though
tony
um
david i said i don't expect it's going
to be some sort of tactical uh operation
but i don't have additional information
today about that
uh and and
quite frankly i'm not sure that that's
all that relevant uh they're going and
they're going to bolster
our capabilities uh in nato and that's
the most important part here
or not you just seem to say no did you
say no david i didn't say no i said i
don't expect that there'll be some sort
of tactical operation here
who will command these troops is it
general walters and is it is that
splitting his role for this well he
already has a split role as a as a
supreme allied commander in europe uh
ultimately he will be the top of the
chain of command for them uh while
they're in europe i don't have
uh you know i don't have more additional
information about the c2 arrangement
right now but we can get that
uh let me go back to the phones here tar
cup
nothing heard carla babb
hey thanks for doing sorry john i'm on i
didn't meet myself i mute myself
um can you talk about what of whatever
additional airlift capacity might be
needed to shift these troops um and what
role our mobility command would uh play
in this
uh i don't have specifics on the airlift
here
tara obviously um uh th this is a
reasonable amount of forces that uh that
will uh
that air mobility command will be able
to to transport i i don't uh
i don't foresee there a need for
some sort of surge of airlift activity
to get uh to get these folks over there
go ahead uh that is the scene at the
pentagon uh press secretary john kirby
confirming
further troop deployment to europe and
within europe a thousand repositioning
to romania to augment uh some 900 u.s
troops already in romania france he said
also intends to deploy troops to romania
uh 2 000 troops from the united states
will go to europe from the 82nd airborne
division he said okay let's go straight
to our white house correspondent now
kimberly halcott and kimberly uh mr
kirby also emphasizing u.s forces
will not fight in ukraine will ensure
the robust defense of our allies said mr
kirby
yeah i think it was important to note
some of the critical questions that came
right at the outset of that q a period
immediately following the pentagon
spokesperson statements and it it
indicates a couple of things number one
the the war fatigue that exists in the
united states the questions that we're
hearing from reporters are very
different than we would have heard 20
years ago there was no challenging 20
years ago of the narrative uh now you're
hearing reporters saying why now what
seems to be triggering this deployment
of troops what intelligence is there
that would suggest that these eastern
flank nato partners are at risk in some
way and there didn't seem to be a good
answer to that question and so that's
why you heard a number of reporters
taking another pass at it trying to get
some clarification on it unsuccessfully
uh what we heard from the pentagon there
was the sort of stock answer that was in
his initial statement and that was that
the united states is watching the
movements of russia very carefully and
they don't like what they see they're
acting on the invitation of the nato
countries and that they will not be in
any way
activated inside of ukraine
but instead we'll be working at a sort
of with the host nations where they will
be positioned uh we should point out in
germany there already is a very large
presence of u.s forces at bases there
and there is already a nato base where
these troops will now be going in the
cases of
poland as well as romania
so
what we should note in all of this is
the questions are critical uh another
question that was brought up is why are
you jumping the gun uh so to speak with
respect to the fact that nato has not
exactly uh
had a vote yet with resp regard to this
activating the nato response force and
yet you're already moving these troops
uh because once again the the pentagon
spokesperson keeps saying that uh the
united states is responding to russian
aggression but many could argue that by
positioning these troops that this is an
aggressive or at least provocative act
on the part of the united states uh
acting in advance of any nato vote to
trigger a reactive force would also be
considered potentially uh depending on
what side of this conflict you're on
could also be seen as provocative or
aggressive
and so
it's very important to to look at both
sides of this perspective and what's
interesting i think most of all is as
someone who's covered conflict
in the united states for 20 years or
more now is that reporters are asking
these questions in a way we would not
have seen 20 years ago yeah plenty of
questions what about at the government
level will there be broad congressional
support for this
already there is uh we should point out
that particularly in the u.s senate
there is
and this i should point out is
bipartisan whether it's democrats or
republicans there is a healthy
majority i would say in the u.s senate
that is already drafting legislation to
counter russian aggression and there are
good reasons why
there you have to remember that there
are people that are still angry about
the
meddling in the 2016 u.s election that
many believe cost their party the white
house and they're looking to
settle scores with respect to that
but they also believe that there is
ongoing
monitoring of u.s systems whether it be
through uh backdoor espionage and cyber
attacks
the attacks haven't stopped and so
on capitol hill there is grave concern
that russia continues to meddle in u.s
affairs and they are concerned about the
the activities that are taking place
that were described by the spokesperson
there at the pentagon and so they are
watching this carefully but again it
comes down to the imminence of the
threat at this particular moment the
threats from russia are nothing new
overall
what these reporters are trying to zero
down on is what makes this particular
activation of troops these 3 000 the u.s
president joe biden has activated uh or
or at least is now positioning as of the
last couple of hours what makes this
imminent now what is necessary now that
wasn't needed say two weeks ago and that
question has not yet been answered
all right kimberly thanks for that for
the time being kimberly hackett there in
washington dc let's get the view
from moscow dawson jabari is standing by
there endorser early days yet but any
comment any response
yes we've actually just been hearing
from the
first deputy head of the foreign affairs
committee here from the duma
the mp by the name of dmitry novokov
he's reacted very quickly saying that
this is an absolutely destructive step
and not only complicates the situation
at the moment but also makes things in
ukraine very complicated he also went on
to say that these actions can also be
qualified as an attempt to hack the
fragile negotiation process that are
ongoing about the security guarantees
this country is looking for from the
americans so it appears that the
russians are already seeing this as a
very much step backwards and an attempt
by the american government to really um
cut off or delay any kind of
negotiations that they have ongoing with
this country there's a lot of talk about
the diplomatic
efforts that were underway over the past
three weeks
but it appears this move now will only
make things much worse we are waiting
still for president vladimir putin to
speak to his british counterpart boris
johnson later this evening and we will
get a briefing from the kremlin about
how that call goes down but of course
this will likely be at the very top of
that conversation the russian president
has been very clear that the americans
are using ukraine as a tool to put
pressure and isolate russia and that is
something this country is not accepting
they say they have very specific demands
from nato and the us and those demands
have been basically ignored by the
american government up to now and that
the dialogue that is ongoing there's
very little
in terms of a solution that the russian
president can see um a way out of it but
he said we must still continue to try
the diplomatic route
after he met with hungarian prime
minister later earlier on tuesday so
we've heard initial reaction from the
duma official but we are going to hear
from the uh russian president later this
evening when his phone call finishes
with boris johnson and the kremlin will
brief us and certainly this announcement
will play very much at the forefront of
that i'm sure it will uh dawson for the
time being thanks very much dawson jabra
there in moscow and let's talk more
about that upcoming phone call rory
challenge is standing by for us
in london uh rory as dawson was just
saying uh british prime minister
scheduled to have this phone call with
vladimir putin at some point in the
coming hours
what's just happened perhaps puts a
somewhat different emphasis complexion
on what they'll talk about
well i think i mean it shows that the
diplomacy continues it hasn't stopped
and even though we have these uh troop
movements deployments obviously the
large number of
russian soldiers poised on the ukrainian
border
all of them essentially are
diplomatic tools they are
threats that you can use warnings that
you can use uh in order for the
politicians to talk out what their goals
and their aims really are
and that's what boris johnson and
vladimir putin are going to be doing
when they speak later on now
will this move the diplomatic needle in
any particular direction will it ease
the situation we'll have to see but the
indications are from the russian side
recently
they don't hold british diplomacy in
particularly high regard at the moment
and of course boris johnson is going
through his domestic upheavals at the
moment
mired in scandal over partygate you can
only imagine really how that's going
down in the kremlin vladimir putin
probably having a good old chuckle about
his uh british counterparts woes at the
moment and probably thinking that
there's no way that he would ever get
himself in such a pickle given his
control over her parliaments over
the judiciary over the police and over
the media in russia a very different
political system
from the uk perspective you have
obviously a collection of different
values uh and interests that are at play
here
on the uh
on the values ledger you have with the
british trying to show that they are
uh
a bold and important part of the free
worlds that they are foreign policy
actors that brexit hasn't diminished
britain it's enhanced its ability to act
uh interests you have well the uk is
trying to
bolster its relations with uh with
the united states it's trying to bolster
its relations with countries like poland
ukraine and the baltic states
and it's trying to stand up for a young
democracy against a bigger neighbor an
autocratic neighbor we can hear boris
johnson articulating some of some of
these views right now
we stand with the people of ukraine and
we stand for the sovereign and
territorial integrity of ukraine at a
very difficult time because there are on
the borders of ukraine as everybody
knows about 125 000 uh russian troops
massing uh the situation is is very
perilous and the job of the uk is to
lead the west in bringing together uh
the most important countries in uh
creating a package of economic sanctions
that will deter president putin from
what i believe would be a disastrous
miscalculation from boris johnson the
job of the uk is to lead uh the western
world now
there is also another lens that you can
look at this through that's the domestic
political lens of course boris johnson
as i mentioned marred in scandal at home
any kind of uh issue that he can
lean into that might give a distraction
to those domestic woes he's going to do
that and of course a big crisis in
ukraine is a good opportunity
indeed rory thanks for that rory
challenger in london